certaines de ces propositions seront
aussi présentés dans le cadre des
élections européennes
alors comme l'ensemble du processus a
vocation à être transparent et j'ai
d'ailleurs fait en sorte qu'un comité de
surveillance entièrement trans partisan
soit monté en france pour que tous les
partis politiques puissent voir comment
les consultations citoyennes sont
organisées et ce qu'elles produisent
leurs résultats de ces consultations
citoyennes seront à la disposition de
l'ensemble des partis qui présenteront
des candidats aux élections européennes
on ne pourra pas dire qu'on ne sait pas
ce qu'attendent les citoyens européens
on ne pourra pas non plus à leur place
se dresser en tant que représentant du
peuple sans les avoir écoutés d'abord